LOUIS GRAY: Welcome back to
Google Developers Live at I/O.
I'm Louis Gray broadcasting here
from the Moscone Center
in San Francisco.
I have not one, but two,
distinguished guests with us
today to talk about
Google+ Sign In.
We have a director of product,
Seth Sternberg.
As well as director of
engineering David Glazer from
the Google+ project.
So thank you both
for coming in.
SETH STERNBERG: Thanks for
having us Appreciate it.
LOUIS GRAY: Thank you.
So this has actually been a
really incredible conference,
with a 3 and 1/2 hour keynote,
full of content,
back to back to back.
We just had a really solid
discussion with Bradley
Horowitz about the three major
pieces of Google+ that were
introduced yesterday, talking
through the stream design, the
Hangouts application, and all
the photos experience.
And very recently, we introduced
Google+ Sign In.
And this is kind of your baby.
And so we definitely wanted to
talk to the developers--
the many thousands of developers
who are watching on
a live stream and those who
will watch after the fact.
We wanted to talk about Google+
Sign In, and say what
it is and how it's impacting
developers.
So maybe we could start with
that at the very beginning.
You can tell us a little bit
about Google+ Sign In, what it
does, and how you guys arrived
at delivering the product as
it is today.
DAVID GLAZER: So, I think the
best way to understand Google+
Sign In is to start by
understanding what problem we
were trying to help developers
and users solve.
And the problem was, we think
there's an opportunity to make
everything users do online
better by bringing the power
of Google with you when
you go to the apps and
sites that you use.
And at the same time, take what
you're doing in those
apps, and bring it back to
Google, to make the whole
experience better
for everyone.
So in that context, what
Google+ Sign In
does is very simple.
It allows you to form a
connection between who you are
on Google, your Google+
identity, and who are in the
apps and sites that you use.
So I go to a website, say
opentable.com, and I can sign
in using my Google identity.
Open Table now gets some
information about me from
Google and has access to
other Google services.
And Open Table has the ability
to send information about what
I'm doing back to
me at Google.
LOUIS GRAY: And what kind
of information is that?
If I'm going to sign in with
my Google+ Sign In on Open
Table or any--
I guess you've got like 50-plus
partners here in the Sandbox--
if I'm signing in to Google+
on any of these apps, what
information is being shared?
And does the user know what the
application is asking for?
DAVID GLAZER: Yeah.
So the user, pivoting to the
second part, yes, the user
absolutely knows what's
being asked for.
That was one of the
responsibilities that we took
very seriously in building
Google+ Sign In.
We heard from users we talked
to, that they trusted Google.
And that they were inclined to
like the idea of signing in as
Google, because they knew that
Google was a trusted place to
do that and would do
right by them.
That added a big responsibility
to us to live
up to that responsibility.
To continue to earn and
increase that trust.
The first part of that is making
sure that users know
exactly what is happening.
So specifically, when you sign
in with Google, you see the
big red Sign In With Google.
You click it.
You get a consent dialog.
It's the same dialogue wherever
you're signing in.
It says Open Table--
sticking with the example--
would like to.
And then there's two things.
One is, what information are
you giving permission for
Google to send to Open Table.
And it's your name, your profile
picture, and whenever
public information you
have put out on
your Google+ profile.
LOUIS GRAY: And you
say public.
One of the interesting things
about Google+ is you have that
ability to share privately You
know, Circles have been
something from Google+ from
the very beginning.
DAVID GLAZER: Yep.
LOUIS GRAY: So with Sign In,
we're definitely making sure
that only the content that
you share publicly, the
information about you,
that that's what's
being sent to the app--
DAVID GLAZER: That's right.
LOUIS GRAY: --should they
choose to look at that.
Is that right?
DAVID GLAZER: That's right.
And then the one other thing
that the app gets, under the
user's control, is the list
of people in your Circles.
Not the list of your Circles,
because we think that how you
choose to organize your
relationships--
LOUIS GRAY: But that's
up to you.
DAVID GLAZER: --is
your business.
LOUIS GRAY: And that's
private.
DAVID GLAZER: That's right.
But it's very useful in
many applications.
You can have a better experience
if you're looking
for a movie to watch, knowing
what other people that you
care about, what they're
doing around movies.
If you're looking for news to
read, knowing what the other
people you know, what news
they're reading.
LOUIS GRAY: Sure.
DAVID GLAZER: There's a lot of
ways that developers can build
a better experience if they know
who you are connected to.
So we also give the app that
information about who our
[INAUDIBLE].
LOUIS GRAY: Now Seth, you're
talking before we broadcast
about the 50-plus partners
we have in the Sandbox.
And we just launched Google+
Sign In, or Google Sign In,
about two months ago.
I mean, so what is it?
How did we go about getting
those initial partners, and
what is they're finding really
exciting about bringing Sign
In With Google to their apps?
SETH STERNBERG: That's
a great question.
So as you point out,
this is only a
two-month-old product, right.
So we're very new in market.
And we had 10 great
launch partners.
So we actually recently went
back to them and asked like,
hey, what have you
experienced?
Tell us.
We heard from The Fancy that
Google+ Sign In is
out-performing every other
social login on their system.
Users are more engaged with
it than any other one.
LOUIS GRAY: So what
does that mean?
I mean, you say out-performing
or engaging-- does that mean
more people are using
it in total?
SETH STERNBERG: More people
are signing in, better
conversion.
On the Guardian, they told us
that on the Android, Google+
Sign In is the number one sign
in option, with 41% of the
users choosing Google+
Sign In.
Then SkillPages, who just
launched three weeks ago, so
they're new, they were not an
original launch partner.
Three weeks ago, SkillPages
puts Google+ Sign In out.
Two nights ago, they told us
that we are now 50% of all
social login.
So what's happening is users,
when they have the option to
use Google+ to sign in, are
choosing Google+ in really big
numbers, because
they trust it.
They understand that it will
enable them to do great
things-- to share with their
friends when they want to, or
to really easily download an
Android app, or to bring the
best of their Google experience
with them across
the internet.
But it won't spam
their friends.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
SETH STERNBERG: It's a safe
option for Google, for
users, excuse me.
And it's great for developers,
because they still have really
powerful ways to write
information about what that
user's done in their apps, back
to Google, and then get
more traffic back.
Now you pointed out 54.
We have 54 developers here in
the Sandbox on display, and of
course many, many more than
that, that have now launched
Google+ Sign In.
So we're so happy at the uptake
that we've seen, both
with users--
as witnessed by the Fancy, and
Guardian, and SkillPages--
and with developers choosing
to integrate.
LOUIS GRAY: We saw I was
actually earlier today.
One of our first things that
we did this morning was
highlight a number of partners
from the Google+ Sandbox.
Daniel Siebert went through
and we rolled some of that
video this morning.
SETH STERNBERG: Great.
LOUIS GRAY: I've seen a number
of media partners who are
here, people like the Verge,
and SP Nation, Mashable.
What is it about media that
makes sense to have a sign in
with Google+?
Why is that one of the
first places that's
really taking off?
SETH STERNBERG: Sure.
So, you know, when you're
reading through a story or
watching a video, oftentimes you
really want your friends
or colleagues to participate
in that with you too.
So one feature that we built
is it's very easy for a
publisher to click Send To My
Friends or Watch With Friends.
In that post, when a user is
signed in, or the user clicks
the post and then they'll be
asked to sign in in order to
send it, that's we call
an interactive post.
And it has a button on it.
It's a clear call to action.
So like for a video, Watch.
And when your friend gets
that, and they'll get it
across all of Google properties,
right-- the
Notifier will light up on
Search, and on YouTube, and in
Maps, and in Google+,
on the Android.
It will light up everywhere.
When your friend gets it, and
they click that Watch button,
or they click that Read button,
they are taken right
to that article or that video
in the mobile app, in the
desktop web, wherever
the user may be.
If they don't have the app,
they'll be asked if they want
to download the app.
So it's a way to get your
friends involved with you in
consuming media.
And hey, in the real world, we
consume media with our friends
all the time.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
All the time.
SETH STERNBERG: Now, at the same
time, what the developer
gets out of this is not just a
share that had a very fair
call to action.
But if that user has an Android
device and does not
have your Android app, the user
will be asked if they
want to install your Android
app on your website.
LOUIS GRAY: From the website.
Yeah.
SETH STERNBERG: Right
so you're on that
machine on a website.
You connect using Google+.
And it says, hey, do you want
the Guardian's Android app?
And we're doing this because if
you're making a connection
with the Guardian, then
you probably would
really want their app.
And of course, we only ask
if you don't have it.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
And we know that thanks
to the integration.
One of things we fight about
with Bradley is you see two
things happening.
One with Google+ being some of
that social layer, you have
that ability to understand who
the person is and it ties into
Google Play.
And you know what's
on their Android.
SETH STERNBERG: That's right.
LOUIS GRAY: And you also have
that option to take that next
step of activity.
And you have the unification
of desktop and mobile.
And so one of the big things
with the design of Google+
that was just redone, but you
have that kind of getting from
desktop to the mobile experience
should be the same.
SETH STERNBERG: That's right.
LOUIS GRAY: And that's been
something that's been echoed
repeatedly.
And you were talking about the
percentage of [INAUDIBLE].
SETH STERNBERG: So, yeah.
So it's so powerful.
It's not only do we give this,
offer you this, 40% of users
who are asked if they want your
Android app, say yes.
That is incredible.
If you think about lots of
developers are purchasing ads
to get Android app installs
or IOS installs.
And maybe they get
1% who say yes.
This is 40 times that.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
SETH STERNBERG: 40% of users
say yes, I want the app.
And then even better, just
announced yesterday is when
the user then picks up their
tablet or picks up their
mobile phone and taps on
your Chicklet, you are
already logged in.
So if you've connected on web,
you are automatically
connected on mobile, and vice
versa, if you do mobile first.
LOUIS GRAY: And once you've
already done it one time, why
go through the process
a second time.
SETH STERNBERG: That's right.
Unbelievably seamless experience
for users and for
developers.
They can give you so much
better experience.
Because now you've got your
account, you have your
shopping cart, you have your
preferences, stories you've
bookmark, your friends--
all of that is just now
available across devices.
LOUIS GRAY: Now speaking of
getting started on some of
this stuff, how do developers
start with Google+ Sign In?
Like where are they
suppose to go?
We've got 50 plus people
here today.
I'm hoping next year we have
more than that for some
incredible stories.
SETH STERNBERG: It'll be hard.
We'll run out of space.
LOUIS GRAY: Moscone just
for G+ Sign In.
How's that?
SETH STERNBERG: There you go.
LOUIS GRAY: But so, how do
people get started with
Google+ Sign In?
DAVID GLAZER: Go to
developers.google.com/+.
And that's the top
of the tree, and
that'll get you there.
What you'll find there
are samples.
You'll find the quick start.
You'll find full reference
documentation.
You'll find recap of the
features and benefits.
But I can do the quick version
of the quick start right here.
If you have a website, you want
to put a Sign In With
Google button on your website,
you do two things.
The first thing you do is, you
put a line of JavaScript on
your website.
If you're using the +1 button,
you already have the line of
JavaScript.
It's already there.
And the second thing is, you put
in a little bit of mark up
that says g: Sign In button,
and then provide the
parameters that we need.
That's all you do
to your website.
You then have to do some work
on your backend to take
advantage of users
being signed in.
You have to know they're
signed in.
You have to say "Hello Lewis"
when they are signed in.
You have to do whenever other
capabilities you want to add.
But the basics of just getting
a "Hello World" alive on your
site is as simple as I said.
LOUIS GRAY: Right.
Just at
developers.goggle.com/plus.
Now as someone who's been
running Google Developers Live
events for practically a year
now, we regularly have the
Google+ development team and
Google+ platform team coming
in and doing office hours,
showcasing partners, talking
about features.
I know, Seth, you've joined us
a couple of times on that.
So I appreciate that.
And obviously, one of the things
we really want to have
people understand is that they
can connect with you both, and
myself as well, using Google
Developers Live through the
rest of year.
So when you go to
developers.google.com/+ for
all the great Google+ Sign In.
And when you're done,
you go back to
developers.google.com/live to
watch the kind of engagement
that we're having here,
year round.
And so I definitely appreciate
you guys coming and meeting
with me at GDO at
I/O at Moscone.
I think it's a really
special event--
really important for us to talk
directly to developers,
like we're doing.
And for those of you who want
to be seeing this kind of
content every single day,
go to YouTube.com.
Look for Google Developers
and subscribe.
Up next GDO at I/O, we'll be
back at 1:35 to talk about
Maps and walk through
the Map Sandbox.
But until then, we'll
return you back
to your live sessions.
Thank you.
DAVID GLAZER: Thanks
for having us.